欢迎来到知行小酒馆。这是一档有知有行出品的播客节目。
我们关注投资，更关注怎样更好的生活。我是玉白。
就在我们准备这期节目的时候，最新的数据出来了。
报名国家公务员考试的人数，反超了考研报名人数。
这在过去的十几年里，是头一回。
相信你从身边，或许也能感觉到。
这两年，在各种职业或者毕业趋向的选择里，
越来越多的人会把考工放到第一优先级。
可说实话，在看到这组数据的时候，
我内心的第一个反应并不是，哇，好卷。
而是另一个更具体的困惑。
当越来越多的人选择同一个方向的时候，
我们到底对这条路了解多少呢？
关于考工、背考的方法、商案的经验、
网上和补习班都不缺。
那真正稀缺的是什么呢？
是一些很关键，但并不容易提前知道的信息。
比如，一名基层公务员的一天，
时间和精力通常花在什么事情上。
什么样的性格和能力，在这样的系统里，
更容易适应，也更容易有发挥。
再比如，很多人报考的时候，
会在不同城市、不同部门、不同岗位之间反复全衡。
但这些差别，放到真实的工作中，
究竟会怎么影响你的工作节奏和生活状态呢？
这些问题都不是考试技巧能回答的。
而更现实的是，
很多人往往是在真正走进系统之后，
才开始一点一点体会到这些差别。
可到了那个时候，再来理解和调整，
成本往往已经很高了。
所以啊，我们一直很想请这样一位嘉宾，
他对体制内的运行逻辑非常熟悉，
但是又可以跳出来，
帮大家把问题看得更清楚。
那今天来到小酒馆的，
是我们的老朋友聂辉华老师。
他是中国人民大学经济学教授。
长期研究政治经济学和组织经济学，
也做了大量和基层政府、企业有关的调研。
很多听友可能还记得，
聂老师之前做课小酒馆的时候，
大家的反馈非常热烈。
最近，聂老师出版了一本新书，
叫《基层中国的运行逻辑》。
这本书顾名思义，
就是在帮你搞清楚，
基层中国到底是怎么运转的。
看完之后，我最直接的感受是，
如果身边再有亲戚家的孩子准备考功，
我肯定让他在报考前先把这本书给读了。
那这一期，和聂老师一起聊天的，
还有小酒馆的人气嘉宾杨天南老师。
感谢天南老师作为客座主播加入我们，
一起把这些看起来宏大。
但其实和每一个具体选择都息息相关的问题，
慢慢聊清楚。
如果你，或者你身边的人，
正在考虑考功、考编，
或者你只是想更清楚的理解，
我们所处的这个环境到底是怎么运转的。
希望这期节目能对你有所帮助。
一个是非常开心，
又请到了聂老师回到我们小酒馆分享他的新书。
另一方面我觉得现在也是一个特别有。
纪念意义的一个时间点。
应该是十几年吧，
考功人数超过了考研，
然后考研人数是从三年前一直往下落。
对，而且还只是统计了国考的人数，
就是审考的人数大概是过考的人数两倍。
所以如果加上这个的话，
那全部的功考人数应该是考研人数的三倍。
对，而且我们现在录制的这一天是国考的结束的第二天。
对。
语白你是哪一年毕业的，本科的时候？
一二年。
一二年的时候考研算是一个主流选项吗？
工作是个主流选项，
考研的也多，
但是我身边，
即便我是一个偏文科的专业，
但是考功的同学非常非常的少，
那个时候会觉得体制内相对有一点点，
没有那么有意思吧，
所以大家考得非常少。
对，至少不是主流选项。
不是主流选项，我零一年本科毕业，
那个时候全班只有几个人考功，
也只有几个人考研，
然后我就有个有意思的现象，
胡伦发布中国百富榜，
他说以前的富翁，
主要来自于那个考研的，
别说那些辅导机构，
他后来的富翁更多来自于考功机构的，
最大的那个考功机构。
中工集团？
对，中工的人就是进入了胡伦百富榜，
胡伦通过这个百富榜的排名变化，
明日也补充到了中国的行业的更迭，
和职业选择的倾向。
在之前，就是留学新式鱼米红上了百富榜吗？
对对对。
然后在这好未来上了，
最后才是中工教育上了。
对，所以当我看到聂老师这本。
基层中国的运行逻辑上市的时候，
我想说哇塞，这本书肯定未来会大卖。
因为我觉得现在是大家特别需要的一本书，
尤其是对于年轻人来说，
大家都老是听到说宇宙的进头是考功，
但是考功对他们到底意味着什么，
进入体制内，
他们的工作状态是怎么样的，
以及体制内这三个字到底意味着什么，
其实很多人是萌萌糊糊的。
我觉得这本书可以帮大家一点一点看清楚，
就是我觉得一个基本的架构，
尤其是基层机制的基本架构。
因为原来我看过聂老师女B站的那个课程，
当时怎么会想到去开这个东西的？
对，很多联系问题，
其实我一开始并不是研究这个的，
就是我一开始那个那是2022年左右吧，
春节过后，
不是每次春节过后会有很多反相体文学作品吗？
就大家微信上会怀念失去的故乡嘛，
所以那个时候我就想看看能写那什么相处的题材的东西，
然后我就觉得应该关注基层的治理，
然后我就想推荐新闻书，
当时的那个B站的运营公司就跟我说，
他是你与其推荐别人的东西不如加上自己的东西，
那我就想讲新闻书记这个吧，
没想到讲了新闻书记的权利有多大那期视频之后，
后来我想为什么大家对这个东西这么感兴趣的，
就是我说的就是中国人对于权力的运行有一种复杂的情绪，
大部分人是没有权力的，
他又很羡慕拥有权力，
他又不了解权力怎么运行，
所以对于那种观察小说为什么会有那么多拥动，
跟这个逻辑是类似的，
比如说我最喜欢的一本历史书之一，
就叫做《教魂》，
《教魂》讲一个什么故事，
就浙江德清县发生了一件事情，
很诡异的事情，
就是民间一些人介入教魂这个巫族的这个流行，
处死了很多外来的人，
就类似中世纪的欧洲的那个女巫，
例如巫型洞，
对对对跟那个差不多，
然后那个作者是那个哈佛大学的孔菲利教授，
他就说这个事情被我透露是什么呢，
就绝大多数普通人并不能享受权力的圣言，
但是一旦有机会分享，
某种透露性是分享权力和了解权力，
他们是不会错过这个机会的。
是的,
我觉得这个心态是一直以来人们心里都会有的一种心态，
更进一步的就是可能我刚才说的，
就是这几年大家真的考虑说，
我得把体质内当成一个自己的一个主流选项，
所以他们很希望能够了解说这个东西到底怎么运作的，
就如果家里没有体质内的人，
他其实是一头霧水的。
对，你说的很重要的信息，
家里没有体质内的人，
他对体质运气是不太了解的，
就是我有些学生，
就是有平民质地，
也有官换质地，
我就很明显的发现，
官换质地，
情商高，
对体质非常了解，
甚至比我还了解，
因为他耳鲁木兰，
严传深教，
这个是巨大的优势。
恩佳老师，
你觉得普通的年轻人对于考工。
或者做工务员最大的误解有哪些呢？
误解,
他们可能觉得当官就一定能够升迁，
这可能是最大的误解，
其实绝大多数人很难升迁，
比方说在基层吧，
90%的工务员只不过于政科级，
99%只不过于付出级，
当然绝大多数人如果不出事，
先考进去的大学生一般都能升到复科级，
可是复科级是最低的一个层级，
所以进入工业就能升官是个最大的误会，
其实就是觉得这是个没有风险的行业，
这也是误会，
我不仅研究官场治理，
我还研究矿难，
以前大家觉得矿难死亡人数最多的，
高峰期2001年，
2002年左右，
每年死六七千的，
这是公开的数据，
但是官员被抓的概率，
其实更高，
反正我只是告诉大家，
地级市市长这一级被抓的概率很高，
现本数据被抓的概率也比较高，
远远超过矿工出现矿能的概率，
可以这么说，
这是很多人看不到的。
对,
这个我深有体会，
因为我在刚开始工作的那几年做记者嘛，
然后当时是在东莞市，
那几年就经历了整个东莞的官场大地震，
无数的这个市委班子，
开着开着会就被抓了，
隔几天抓一个，
从某种意义上，
这确实是一个高危职业，
但是可能很多人会觉得说，
我不求大富大贵，
只求平平安安，
我觉得我是一个职位没有那么高的公务员，
也可以，
但是我这两年，
比如说我会认识一些，
比如在北京的，
尤其是外地来的基层公务员，
我会发现他们也有他们的困境，
首先肯定这个工作很稳定，
他有宿舍包吃，
但是他们工资收入其实是相对有限的，
他们也很难看到一个掌心的可能性，
我不知道这个是不是说，
就是有一些30岁以上的这种部委的公务员，
他的收入月薪可能是一万以下的。
很多,
就是我最了解的是金融行业，
因为最近几年金融反腐各种各样的原因出来以后，
实际的收入是大幅下降的，
而且原来一些，
就是我在机关里边做了做了，
我是有可能调到金融机构去的，
但现在这条路径也被掐断了，
也就意味着说，
实际上他们去可能管的是一个万亿十万亿的行业，
但实际上他们触及的这种处长级别的人，
可能也只能拿到一万两万的，
甚至更低的一个收入，
就这样的情况其实是比较普遍的，
所以行业内再开个玩笑吧，
就是只有富二代才能执行考供理想了，
因为他本身门槛很高，
腰就很高，
需要你有很强的能力，
但与此同时他的这个薪酬，
其实并没有想象当中那么好，
至少相比较过去十年二十年以来，
他的性价比是持续下降的。
我觉得这个是分层的，
你说富二代才是要考供，
这可能稍微有点极端，
对于大城市来说，
确实是如果没有很好的经济基础的话，
做个普通公务员是非常辛苦的，
但是如果你是一个农村出生的，
或者是十八县小镇出生的人，
你要去基层当公务员，
相对来说还是有优势的，
去基层，一个是回家商能照顾家里人，
第二个是在基层的生活压力比较小气嘛，
对于基层公务员来说，
普通人的出生不是问题，
仍然是一个非常好的选择之一，
相对而言，
但是大城市确实不一样，
所以就是可能将来出生好的人，
更适合去大城市或者是考国家部委的公务员，
但是如果基层和部委的公务员本身就缺少流动的话，
这可能在另一种程度上会加剧社会的阶层固化，
比如说我本科的年我就考工了，
考的是国务员一个部门，
我记得比赛还是部门第一名，
就是面试被刷掉了，
那那个时候根本就没有这种阶层的观念，
就是大家觉得反正房子都会分，
这个也不存在多大的收入差距，
那现在就不好保障了，
本来公务员队伍相当于古代的科举，
科举在中国古代那是神一般的存在呀，
它其实受到人们的价值观，
很多人忽略这点，
就是西方国家它是靠选举受到合法性，
中国最主要的是靠考试，
中国觉得只要是考试能录用的，
本身就具有极大的正当性，
所以这是历代统治，为什么这么重视科举，
所以一旦一个地方霸考，
那是非常严重的事情，
那么放到今天很多人忽视了中国的考试制度，
零选制度，公务员考试制度，
是受到合法性的一个重大来源，
所以如果公务员的合法性受到了挑战，
这就是一个比较值得关注的问题了。
那一个比如说现在一个年轻人，
他如何判断说自己到底适不适合当公务员呢？
我个人来看吧，
用一句话来看过去，
他是不是情商高，
如果说的具体点，
你是不是眼睛比较尖，
耳朵比较零，
对吧，然后嘴巴比较紧，
腿比较轻，
闻味比较好，
口才比较好。
听起来像个玩人。
不，不，不，不需要成为玩人，
他可能不需要创建能力，
他也不一定要非常聪明，
他甚至不需要特别的综合老师。
不大局，有大局观的人。
但这个就觉得要做不到，
所以其实要我说，
比较多数人并不适合当公务员。
这不容易做到，要我就做不到。
然后我现在问，
如果我的学员要考工，
我就问他一个问题，
假如你跟你同学同研进去，
三年之后，
他变成科长了，
你是他的下手，
你能不能平淡地接受这点，
他说做不到，
我说做不到你就别考工了，
这是很常见的，
对吧，甚至不需要你的同学，
比你玩两年的人都变成你上司，
你要是不能接受，
又表达怨言，
那你完蛋了，
我说你在学校，
你看我对领导有愿也无所谓，
反正抬头不见，
低头也不见，
上课我就走了。
这个其实和很多人。
对于体制内的想象不太一样，
他我觉得说，
我都进体制内了，
就算你看不惯我，
你也很难把我怎么样。
不不不，
这完全是个误会。
比如我举个例子，
我有一次去那个一个地方调研，
我就问一个线委书记，
我说你手下干活的人，
可能有高数字的，
也有低数字的，
因为这个线里嘛，
这里能力有限。
我说有人不听你的话，
然后呢，
你又没什么基地手段，
给钱啊，
给物资啊，
语诺帽子啊，
破个提拔都不能用啊，
那你怎么办？
他说聂老师，
那我没什么好的办法，
那谁愿意干我就提拔那些能干的人，
他不干，
我不理他不就行了吗？
我确实不能开了他，
你看他把你血藏了，
那你想想看，
公务员的提拔是跟领领和资历有关的，
如果你又不承担重要的任务，
对吧,
又没有领导喜欢你，
然后呢又被耽误了领领，
你怎么可能提拔呢？
如果你愿意说这样的人，
那你愿没接受另一个后果，
二、三十年了，
你最后以一个副科技主任科员的身份退休了，
你愿意吗？
那就只能调整心态了，
对啊,
那之后呢，
年龄放宽了，
你还说我们人大的换了一个校长，
大家都关注到了，
郑柏大学的校长来人大的，
他是六十岁，
六十岁正常情况下，
听见干部说退休了，
郑柏大学是听见单位，
然后他到我们人大当校长，
校长是副部席，
他在六十岁的时候，
你们一脚还提升了，
这到过去是不可思议的，
当然高校相对有点特殊，
他对年龄要求没那么宽，
现在普遍情况下，
高校和副部席干部可以干到六十三，
过去一般都是六十岁退休，
所以现在确实相对于以前来说，
年龄放宽了一点点。
嗯,
就是您在书里也写了这个现象嘛，
我觉得这个对于大部分人来说，
他感觉像这个积极的型号，
就是年龄上不再那么一刀切，
你有能力的人，
你是可以继续发光发热更久的。
看什么人？
如果你是个完全没有背景的人，
其实卡年龄对你反而有优势，
年龄到了就提拔，
我举个例子，
我去一个地方调研，
一个现场数据给我讲一件很有趣的事情，
他说现在每一个部门或者单位。
都有一些所谓的结构性干部，
举个例子，
你的班子里面必须有个80后，
正好有个人就是80后，
其实他刚刚提拔，
但是因为你没有别的人，
就马上又把他提拔了，
然后甚至他的上次都没提拔，
他提拔了，
但是后来他又发现很有意思，
哎,
那个刚提拔的能力确实不太盛任，
但是你提拔了，
你不能把他降下去，
怎么办呢？
给他调一个岗位，
但即便还保留，
这是真实，
所以你看，
硬杠杆里面什么东西最硬，
年龄是最硬，
最不容易造假，
现在组织部对档案卡的非常严，
你其他东西都是软的，
能力,
德行,
品行,
都不好说啊，
我并不说这不重要，
是他没有像年龄那么显得可证时，
最后更感觉，
没有那么显性，
就多会以前说，
对对对的人士知识分子，
少数族裔女性，
更容易提拔，
因为在一个班子里边，
他要保持这样的一种结构性干部，
这就是结构性干部，
但现在这个东西还强调吗？
还是说实际上这两年，
其实是没有那么强调呢？
结构性干部一直都存在，
只不过重点可能不一样，
比较说举个例子，
可能以前呢，
是你几个条件都得有，
现在可以把几个条件合并了，
那一个人就可以了，
以前可能要两三个人，
来站这个位置，
就合并了，
所以这个竞争其实也相当于变激烈了，
可以这么说，
对，其实我就觉得，
总结一下前面说的，
现在当公务员，
一个是风险大，
第二个是收入低，
第三个是近身可能比较慢，
那还不会有没有一个风险，
叫做躺不平，
我现在接触到的很多的公务员，
和饭公务员的这些事业单位的人，
我普遍的感觉，
用一个字来形容就是忙，
就每个周末我去参加活动的时候，
会发现他们一直在忙，
然后上个礼拜见到他们，
周末没有休息，
这个礼拜见到他们，
周末又没有休息，
我就很纳闷，
我就觉得说，
你们现在感觉比民营企业，
比互联网大厂还要绝，
对，你说对，
躺不平也是，
其实以前的，
反正没这么严，
别说举兵在基层，
你一般52岁就退居二线了，
把职位逞给年轻人，
现在不行了，
退居二线的干部，
赞扬也回来报道，
要上班，
你想想，如果你是领导，
没有一个领导愿意看到，
手下一帮人闲着，
不，这跟体制都没有关系，
其实在所有的体制中，
你看到老板，
你都装得很忙的样子，
这是很正常的，
就像看到老师，
要装得很认真读书的样子，
对呀,
你想如果，
你跟老师说，
老师在看论文，
你在打游戏，
你想老师会对你什么印象？
对,
这个也是我们在，
录之前讨论的时候说到嘛，
就是,
感觉现在体制内就越来越像体制外一样，
就是忙碌，
非常的卷，
然后事情很多，
其实包括我和一些体制内的朋友打交道，
我自己的体感，
我是感觉体制内的这些，
尤其是年轻人，
大家的素质越来越高，
就很多人会觉得说，
宇宙的镜头是烤边，
似乎是，
听起来像是去躺平，
但是我有会遇到一些，
很有想法，
很希望能做出一些事情的人，
对,
我同意你的关系，
就是说，
现在体制内的单位越来越像体制外，
体制外的单位也越来越像体制内，
大家相互学习，
这个也是个好事嘛，
比方说举个例子，
体制内，
它有那个招商部门，
招商部门是真能感，
像我经常研究那个企业问题嘛，
跟说我会问很多搞政府引导基金的人，
我说很多市场都看不准的事情，
凭什么你们能看得准，
直到今天也没有人能够完美的回答我这问题，
但是他们就告诉我，
他说现在的情况没有你想的那么糟，
就是你以为我们这些招商部门的人，
是像普通官员一样，
对市场一无所知，
不是的，
我们到处跑，
到处看，
我们上下常用链，
到处都看了，
也听了很多专家的讲解，
没吃过猪肉也见过猪跑了，
所以他们也是比较专业的，
而且我还问过一个基金经理，
他以前是在一个市场化的投资机构，
现在去了一个国资的投资机构，
他就说在机率体制上，
市场化的投资机构和国资的投资机构也没有太大的差别，
所以你看，
体制内也在吸收一些市场化的机制，
包括政府引导基金本身就是一种偏市场化的机制，
那余志东是呢，
体制外的单位，
比如说民营协，
他也在吸收一些体内的一些优点，
比较搞笑的就是那个政委，
有些企业有政委，
只不过内部可能不这么叫，
还有地方要写内餐，
内餐绝对是个体制内的说法，
那企业也必须把这个方法引入，
就是你任何员工或者下属有意见，
都可以直接写公司的意见建议，
通过专门的去到地上个老板介绍内餐，
更不用说现在很多民营协稍微大点规模的普遍建立的党委，
一开始我去下面调演的时候，
我总觉得他们会不会担心党委是一种流于形势的活动，
挂个牌子，
然后上去来参观一下，
或者我一问，
人家觉得这玩意真有用，
和工人的工作是要通过工会去做的，
工会是一个中介，
咱们中国也有工会，
但工会的作用主要不是这个，
它就找不到抓手，
党委就成了这个工作的抓手，
他要做的工作就是安抚工人，
调节工人，
对，提高权价值，
然后协调劳子冲突，
我就问过一个党委书记，
党委书记是副总裁，
我说你是站在老板这边，
还站在工人这边，
他说两面都得站，
首先我是老板骗情的，
我不能网顾公司的利益，
但与此同时，
我是党委嘛，
我要是反映工人的意见，
我以党委的名义反映，
那对方就必须得重视，
因为如果对方不重视，
我可以跟上级党委直接通气，
他这个上上的通道就打通了，
所以在这个程度上，
如果这个党委书记是老板聘用的，
那他肯定是大部分时候是为老板服务的，
与此同时又能起到沟通工人的情绪，
以及安抚管理者的这样一个功能，
所以我觉得真的是很奇怪的一件事情。
对,
我当过两家企业的党委书记，
和那个专职的党委副书记，
其实本账他扮演的是什么，
就是叫做知心大嫂的角色，
就是因为老板构建的那个场域，
他是一个正式的一个谈话场域，
没有人敢轻易说真话的，
大家就害怕说错话，
领导有对我有想法，
或者就把我冷藏了，
但知心大姐找我聊一聊的时候，
相对来说他构建的是一个非正式的一个场合，
就关于一些福利，
公司内的一些组织文化的一些问题，
他愿意沟通，
而且现在民营企办党委在过去几年，
特别是在我所处的那个城市上海的话，
无论是街道还是区里边都是非常支持的，
因为区和街道，
他也是希望找到一个接口去服务在地的民营企业，
那么你如果你没有党委或者是党支部的话，
这个连接就很难建立了，
对，他没有工作的抓手，
他没有工作抓手，
但是你建起来以后，
哪怕平时去借他的场地，
他来去做一些交流，
他其实都会有一个连接和抓手在，
我觉得这个是很明显，
特别是在比如说互联网的那个方向，
你会发现说在很多中大型的互联网公司，
他的那个GR部门，
GR部门的leader，
往往都是来自于政府部门的一些前员工，
那他也会把原来的他的那套打法，
那套管理的一些方式，
企业文化的那套东西带到民营企业当中去，
这个是在过去几年中大型的一些民营企业当中，
非常典型的一个特征，
对我差距就是很多地方，
就是让党委书记负责那个GR部门，
你要一般情况下，如果你质负的GR部门，
你要跟政府达到你没有理由，
你不是政府的人，你凭什么向政府汇报工作，
你现在是党委书记的，
你跟政府党委系统建立了直接的联系，
你可以以党委的民营汇报工作，
你看这样就同时更好处理了政企关系，
他说白了就是说，
两个功能一，对外建立政企关系，
对内安抚功能，
所以这个功能我开始我如果不调研，
我绝对想不到，
因为基于纯粹的西方经学的观点，
我会认为这个太形式主义了吧，
现在发现不是这样的，
所以你看调研，
才能理解真实世界的经济学，
嗯，但是不管怎么说，
我觉得国企或者说体制内和体之外，
之间它的组织文化，
权力结构还是有很大的不同的，
而且彼此之间的误解还是很多的，
就是我建国挺多的，
我身边的朋友原来，
可能是从外地到上海，
多大学，
然后留在上海，
到互联网或者是媒体工作了几年，
后面就觉得压力太大了，
我就回老家了，
去做了一个事业单位或者是公务员，
但是这种适应的过程是很漫长的，
甚至是很痛苦的，
第一是来自于组织文化和大城市的那种，
管理和那种风格是完全不同的，
第二个是对于收入的预期也会发生很大的一些变化，
就原本，
大家认为说，
哎，我都进了体制内了，
或者进了事业单位了，
我收入应该非常的稳定，
至少能够到底发工资，
但事实上来说，
其实这几年因为，
整个地方上的财政不成好，
这个情况也在发生变化，
这是我看到很惊讶的一个地方，
对，所以我觉得，
它在更红大的一个背景是什么，
就是我在那本基层中国的治理逻辑里面谈到，
就是中国的体制它是一个等级制，
这个越往上正式制度越重要，
越是期向于完全契约，
越往下非正式制度越重要，
越是期向于一个不完全契约，
所以其实越往下人情关系越重要，
很多人不能适应的一个重要原因，
是因为除了收入之外，
工作机会之外，
还有就是人情事故，
别人去小城镇，
那你每年过节送你吃饭，
请客一大堆事情，
但大城市你，
说了极端点你都可以一年到头都不请客，
都可以活下来，
但是小城市根本不行，
所以很多人觉得小城市压力小，
可是它无法适应那个人情压力，
觉得大城市压力大，
但是大城市兴满，
相对来说，
那你活得比较自在一点点，
这个圈上去的时候，
我觉得很长时间都不会消失，
就是我之前看过一些书就讲中国古代的治理，
就有点大家可能难以想象，
以清朝为例，
清朝离我们最近嘛，
县里面只有一个县官，
也就是县令是政府正式官员，
其他的几乎所有的官员，
几乎所有的官员都不是政府雇用的，
都是他自己聘用的，
而且整个财政体系没有给这个县官。
留下任何合理的收入，
就是合法的收入，
你的自己去筹资，
还不起债，
你要承担无限廉贷责任，
这个在今天看来简直不可思议，
但为什么这套体系能运转下来，
靠的就是到非正式之头，
就这套非正式包括，
有乡绅，
有那么多疏利，
有那么的牙译，
还有自己的事业，
然后他还有自己的学道去获取这个。
国家治理的基础信息，
包括人口啊，
土地啊，
税收啊，
田母啊等等，
你会发现，
这简直在今天看来是不可思议的，
所以我越研究中国的继承治理，
我就越发现，
我们还是要多看点历史的东西，
才能理解中国是怎么到这一步的，
所以我想借这个机会告诉他，
就说,
我们现在很多人就觉得，
我们不够现代化，
我们不够西方化，
但很有可能，
股子里很多东西是短信的不可改变的，
就我讲一件事情，
大家可能觉得难以思义，
20年前,
假设我们村里有两个人打架斗，
一个人有礼，
一个人没礼，
有礼的人可能不小心把那个没礼的人给打死了，
你要是今天肯定要杀人长命，
但是不一定哦，
在20年前，
这个是可以私了，
司法员可以揭露，
司法员一问情况，
一个人没礼，
一个人有礼，
没礼的人被有礼的人打死了，
那这个情愿可怨，
如果这个有礼的人愿意出点钱，
没礼的那个家庭愿意接受这个和解，
这个事情可能就过去了，
我在几十年前这种事，
可不一定是少见了，
这个大家可以看那个，
北戴法院前院长朱叔绿协规本书叫做宋法下乡，
一开始的故事就跟我讲的类似的，
他为什么叫宋法下乡呢？
就过去我们讲，
黄泉不下县，
当然黄泉不下县这个命令本身有争议啊，
我们不管他，
那今天所以我想说的是，
我们很多人想去继承当公园，
他有没有考虑清楚这背后的政治经济背景差异啊，
他能适应那种高度人格化的社会吗？
他能够适应那种非契约化的人情关系吗？
他能知道那些丰富民情，
以至能够参与有效的机身治理吗？
很多人可能压个没口的这个问题，
他只想着机身的公园相当来是好考，
我先上岸，
这个想法我觉得有点道理，
但是呢，
如果没有看到我哥哥说的那个巨大的背景差异的话，
这个真的可能是一个错误的选择都有可能。
嗯,
我自己有个很深切感受，
因为我本科是在北京，
毕业了以后，
是被派到一个地级室的项目，
这其实还是一个江南水箱，
一个比较大的一个地级室，
但你会发现当中的人情网络非常的发达，
就是你到文英店去印东西，
他一看照片，
文英店的老板可以认识照片里的大多数的人，
就是整个场面上有头有脸的人极其有限，
你去吃个饭，洗个脚，
服务员张口就知道你说的是谁，
他来自于哪里？
就是你看到，
你不能随便讲八卦，
你看到整个地级是很大，
但是地级室当中市区可能就二十来万人，
有头有脸的可能就是那个几百个人，
然后这几百个人，
他们的组织是非常紧密的，
就你会发现说，
他们在一起打篮球，
他们在一起吃饭，
然后整个场面上的大事小勤，
其实都是这100个200个人在撑着，
而且到了现如今也是一样，
就我们有共同朋友，
他在北京的一个重要的职能，
就是接待老家来的干部，
为什么？
因为他在老家是个有头有脸的人，
老家的人到北京来办所有的事，
看病，入学，跑关系，
他都要去对应的去接待，
所以就是我们现在看到的大城市的一个规则，
是北上广深的，
或者说至少是一二线城市的一些规则，
但是几千个县级市和这个县城，
他们的人情社会的那种关系，
其实和我们一线大城市的新市民的理解是有脚大的一个差别，
对,
你想这个特别点心，
我越听越觉得就像我们那个地方一样的，
就是我要顺便补充一个视角，
你讲到就是说，
当地有一些政治精英和经济精英或者文化精英，
他们是一张网络，
在这张明的网络之外，
还有一张暗网，
就是当地的士生，
讲到那个杨老师，
你在北京或者在上海当官，
你就属于当地的士生，
那这条线也是连接来的，
就是家里的人来北京或者来上海要找你，
这条线也越来越重要，
为什么呢？
因为现在的大城市，
现在的部委，
拥有了比过的更多的资源，
而且联系更紧密，
我以为去拜访一个商会的会长，
我就问他，
我说你这个商会的会长，
谁能决定你这个位置，
不是商会的会员，
也不是北京，
他在北京驻车商会，
是当地的父母官决定的，
然后他就很自豪地说，
他说我这个位置很重要，
我相当于住进办，
而且他说，
家生很多地方赶到好，
是我们这些在外地的人一起帮忙做起来的，
他都把自己删除到这么高的地位，
就可以想象，
他一定帮家生做了很多事，
所以这些是暗线，
很多人也看不到，
所以现在问题在于，
如果你是个外地人，
你考了当地的一个公务员，
你怎么融入当地的社会？
你第一不属于本地的经营网络，
第二你又没有那张暗网，
你只能接触显性的那些关系，
但是你看不到背后的隐性的关系，
而背后的隐性的关系那种巨大的网，
才决定了资源的配置，
我在书里面有一句话总结就是，
能跟资源走，
资源跟着权力走，
权力嵌入等级中，
我觉得这套逻辑其实，
自古以来在中国任何地方几乎都起作用，
所以我一再告解现在的学生，
不要老是觉得价格在资源配置中起决定作用，
什么东西到处都是市场经济，
并不是这样的，
你想象一下对吧，
中国古代曼陀的那么长时间，
别说市场经济连市场都可能没有，
人们是怎么配置资源的？
我经常让大家思考这个问题，
一遍反思西方军学那些，
相对来说比较明确，
但有可能不完全反映当代现实的一些经济学理论，
但一般人不太能理解，
其实学生毕业之后他要工作，
那请问他们怎么能够理解社会，
怎么能够好融入社会呢？
所以我觉得我们特别缺这种书，
就是学生在校的时候就已经知道社会怎么运行的，
其实我写这么说的目的之一就是这个，
其实我写的东西我觉得都是常识，
可是为什么大家都不知道呢？
而且很奇怪的事情也没有一本架构书告诉大家。
每个人定义的常识都不一样。
好吧，这可能是一个问题。
对，就像您前面说的公务员家庭出生的小孩，
他觉得这些东西真的是常识，
但是一个体制外的，
尤其是相对弱势的一个社会地位的成长出来小孩，
这些对他来说就是跟天书一样，
他从来没想过原来世界是这个样子的。
对。
就是以前我的体制里的想象可能就是基于比如课本或者影视剧，
但现在发现说其实每个图壤上的，
他的这样的一个体制他肯定都是非常的复杂的。
对，是的，就是现实社会可能不像纸牌物那么黑暗，
但也绝不会像我爱我家那么和谐，
我觉得更多的介于中间状态，
就是不管是中国社会还是西方社会，
关系和权力在志愿配置中足起了非常重要的作用，
这是不可否认的。
其实在经济学中关系和权力往往是一个中性词，
只不过在我们日常生活中我们好像，
你要中国人关系就基本上是个负面词，
但是在西方它不一定是个负面词，
它可以换一个词，可那个讯。
对,Network。
对，Network，这就变成一个证明词了。
这为什么呢？
我觉得要铺的这个迷信、这个误会，
就尤本书写的很好，就是叫做权力，
为什么只为某些人所拥有，
这是史党夫一个教授写的，
其实权力就是一种工具，
你想实现你的目标，
你想有所作为，你就得拥有权力，
权力越大，你干的事情才能越多，
但是你获取权力的路径，
当然必须是合法的。
所以我觉得我们可能中国人对权力区妹，
就是我们总觉得权力是一个不好的东西。
我给中欧商选的一言别讲课我就告诉他们，
我讲一门课，这个公司这里有权力运行，
我会告诉他们，
你如果你是个有道德洁癖的人，
你不适当要管理者，
因为管理者你一定要拥有权力，
如果你没有权力，你可能会被权力碾压，
那你能不能接受呢？
那向宁老师，你怎么看，
就是这些年大家还是会热议，
比如说像一些非常王牌的大学的毕业生，
他可能最后去街道做一些基层公务员，
然后引起了就是，
比如说微博、小红书上的热议。
当辅警的都有。
对。
当辅警可能是临时岗位，
但是去街道办，去城管，
那可是正式编制。
是。
我觉得从社会最余的角度讲，
那肯定是资源的错配，
或者是人才的错配。
为什么呢？
因为越往基层啊，
越不需要创新能力，
越不需要研究能力，
他都玩博士了，
博士是要做理论思考的，
基层不需要理论思考，
基层就是要当好罗斯丁，
比如你街道，
就是执行党媒，
你都没有任何致敬政策的权力，
你说你去了一个区，
或者去了一个现代研究部门，
我觉得那还有点价值。
而且我觉得绝大都是基层的工作，
本身就可以干好。
现在学历炒得那么高，
完全是因为过度信号发射的原因，
我们经学中有一种理论叫的信号发射理论，
就是读书，考大学，拿文凭，
是为了向别人证明自己的能力，
就在一个信息不兑现的世界里，
你要做一件别人不容易做到的事情，
你现在跟别人区分开来，
但这件事情本身有可能完全是浪费时间和资源，
那读书一定可能就是这样的，
所以才会出现一支卷，
读完本科，读博士，读博士，读博士，读博士，读圣斗士，
这可能是无情无尽，
我觉得从整个社会上真的是一个资源的浪费，
所以如果有好的机制，
应该避免这种学历的高消费，
这属于学历通胀。
诶，你会用这条理论跟你的学生讨论吗？
我会告诉他们，
就是我给研究生讲七月理论的时候，
我就会讲一部分，
三个另一模型，
三个另一模型就是信号发射模型，
我就会告诉他们，
什么时候这个信号是有效的，
什么时候这个信号是无效的，
别人如果整个社会都需要公务员，
必须是博士，
那肯定过度了，
那你就不应该去干这个事情，
政府也还是要给老百姓更多的出路，
就是我们现在的问题就是，
前面说的我们重视考试，
考试一成为合法性的来源，
但是我们又过于重视考试，
把所有的东西都规及到考试，
因为博士就是考出来的，
这是一个问题的两个方面，
他衍生了很多负面的效果，
他不能接受非单向的思维，
就是好像必须是线性思维，
读书就一定要读到头，
还是没有给大家更多的出路，
为什么也给大家更多，
因为很多出租他们不放用考试的衡量，
别人说创新，
别人你去农村搞一个文创小店，
他跟考试无关，
所以我觉得我们在国家这里前面，
要开始能解决这个问题就是，
不通过考试也能够凝聚人心，
那这样的制度创新就是非常有必要的，
他就不会那么内卷。
嗯，但我觉得对于很多的孩子来说，
他在整个成长过程当中，
他接受的都是一种阴染的设定，
就是我考试是获得某种许可，
我获得了这个许可，
我理应就应该获得某种回报，
如果放在15年前、20年前，
当时大学生比较稀缺的时候，
我2007年比较那时候全中国400万本科大学生，
就是供不应求的，
那你到现在一年一千多万大学生，
但是你提供的新增岗位没有那么多的情况下，
那你原来的那个设定他一定就发生一些变化，
但是对于很多的年轻的孩子，
他没有经过社会化的训练以后，
他是不知道的，
因为他的中学高中老师不知道，
还用的是老的设定，
他的父母不知道，
他父母身边的亲戚也不知道，
他就被茫然的抛进了高校，
然后在高校里边还按照原来的那个经历，
现在就不是叫做大学那个高中化嘛，
进了大学以后就师哥师姐开始给他们辅导说，
你如果是工作的话，
你应该先去哪些地方实习，
你要去考研考工的话，
你现在就要准备起来了，
他依然还是那种我经过哪些历练，
拿到哪些许可，
我就可以得到什么样的一些回报，
他依然是沉浸在这种茫然的一个思维当中，
这个东西他其实我觉得相比较我们过去会更加的严重，
对，你刚才说的那个问题我觉得，
也不能怪他们，
因为人都是有现行思维，
举个例子，
在2021年之前，
我如果说房价会跌，谁会信呢？
虽然大家经济学上都知道，
世界上没有子长不跌的东西，
但是你绝对不相信，
他就会马上跌，
你不愿意相信，
所以大家依据过去的经验来推测未来，
这是一种常见的思维方式，
所有人都会犯这个愁，
就是现行思维，
这就提出一个严峻的问题，
就是在一个时代红利消失的时代，
我们怎么过好一生？
这真的是个很难的问题，
我昨天跟我一个同事讨论这个问题，
我就说，
现在年轻人最需要的是什么？
需要一个梦，
能让他们觉得他们是有希望的，
这太重要了，
我们现在的问题在于我们没有解决这个问题，
我们无法告诉他们，
你们将来怎么能够像我们一样，
享受时代的红利，
通过奋斗就能改变命运，
过上好的生活，
你又问我，
我现在都找不到这样的梦，
我其实很想找这个梦，
因为否则的话，
我总是面对年轻人，
他们会说，
你们这代人，
70%或者80%,。
抓上了时代的红利，
所以你们成功了，
但现在我们没有时代红利，
所以你现在讲这套，
对我们还有什么用呢？
当然我会告诉他们，
首先每一个时代都有竞争，
竞争的方式不一样，
那我也藉此机会想告诉大家，
别说我举个例子，
现在大学生一年能收将近一千万，
在我那个年代，
只能招80万，
我那个时候不是没有竞争，
是竞争在前面更残酷，
我们小学到初中，
30%的人才能上去，
初中到高中，
一个班子能考两个，
高中到大学，
我一个班子考了八个，
所以我的竞争是在前面，
每一班都很残酷，
所以一旦考到大学之后，
后面的竞争区域越来越宽松，
所以你看到我享受的时代的红利，
其实是因为没有看到我前面的一个残酷的竞争，
这属于幸存者偏差，
现在的竞争不是，
竞争后制了，
那当然后面越来越堵了，
这并不是不公平，
这是两种不同的竞争的逻辑，
当然他们会闻那，
我们不谈竞争，
我们来谈时代红利，
你们那个时候至少发展场行业是有红利的，
那你告诉我们我们这个时代，
我们还有什么红利能抓住，
我说我不知道，
因为如果我现在知道的话，
我就在那个地方了，
我也不会告诉你的，
对吧,
但是我相信每个时代都有机会，
永远都有机会，
因为中国是处于一个整体上上升的时代，
这就是最大的时代红利，
其实最大的时代红利，
未必是你现在眼前看到的房地产，
而你要想的是在整个世界格局中，
中国已经处于一个有利的地位了，
在这个大背景下，
找到一个梦，
我觉得应该是有希望的。
嗯,
这中间是不是有一个点，
就我们经常说到红利，
就是趋势和机会在时空上分布的不均匀嘛，
但是有的人他只看到时机上分布的不均匀，
他就觉得对吧，
你们这些中灯老灯都把好处偏远站进来，
我躺在地上吸尾气，
我就只能是时代黑力，
但是我自己的感受就是说，
他在空间上分布的更不均匀，
因为我不知道大家有没有去过一个地方，
叫深圳的那个华强北，
他们都是一些智能的小硬件嘛，
哪怕是一个造插头，
造手机的充电宝的那些荡孔，
那边都排着嘻嘻扬扬，
还有很多一些老外到这边来，
就是全世界很多创新的一些智能的硬件，
他都是在华强北最早被发掘出来，
然后你到那边所有的咖啡馆，
所有的街道，
你看到的都是那些热情仰义的说，
我要不能叫改变世界吧，
就是至少是一个经济上行期的那种状况，
所以我自己感觉就是，
红利在时间上固然它分布是不均匀的，
但它在空间上的分布更不均匀，
这是我自己的一个感触。
我刚才听了有一个好习，
就体制内的这些岗位，
它也存在这种空间上的不均匀。
那肯定呢，
我在毕正的节目和这本书里，
都谈到了就是，
这个按照应该是先选城市，
然后再选那个部门，
再选岗位，
这个不要说逻辑是什么的，
就是我把人事间所有的事情分为两类，
一类是可逆的，
你一定要先选不可逆的，
做好这个选择，
因为可逆的选择你可以反复，
因为城市就是不可逆的，
你在一个地方生活惯了，
你再换一个城市可难了，
但你要是找那个一线城市，
或者发展比较有潜力的城市，
哪怕你在的工作部门不是特别好，
那你可以在这个城市换一个部门，
但你要想换一个城市就非常困难，
所以先选一个好的城市，
或者一个发展潜力的城市，
反过来就说，
要避开那些人口减少的收收性城市，
这样的城市有一百多个呢，
然后在这个城市里你选一个主流的部门，
那部门这样差别很大了，
大家都知道哪些的部门升迁快，
但那些部门活多累，
说不定风险也大，
比如说组织部门纪委，
这都是出火出人的地方，
但是确实压力很大，
一般人也干不了，
然后你去那部门就再选重要的岗位，
即便你在组织部门，
你不能说我去当一个打架的人，
那就不行的，
你不会边缘化的，
所以相当于说，
这一步一步确实很重要，
但是先选哪一个还是有差别的，
我有个通话写了一本书，
张琪和刘明星讲那个温州内代浙江，
为什么会支持民营经济，
他觉得一个重要的背景是权力结构不一样，
就是当时有很多南下干部，
他发现南下干部比较多的地方，
那本地干部就没有权力了，
本地干部没有权力他就寻找知识怎么办呢，
他就去支持民营经济，
他就从这个角度来解释，
为什么江泽的民营经济能够发展起来，
有些地方发展不起来，
这当然是其中一种解释的逻辑，
但是我个人也认为，
其实很多问题是历史的因素，
所以之前好像是上次录节目的时候，
我提到了给年轻人六条建议，
这个降低预期，提高技能，珍惜时间，
断了身体，
需要外语多看历史，
因为你看多历史之后你会发现，
你觉得当下比较正常的事情，
其实在历史上不一定正常，
你觉得当下不太正常的事情，
在历史上可能是个很常见的事情，
大面积考功算正常还是不正常，
考功当了算正常啊，
你是40年对5000年的比啊，
对40年的当年，
你想个治股以来我们那个，
不能说这个也知道，
很长生以来，
起码上千年我们的科举制度，
都是最重要的西南人才的制度，
对吧,
回到刚才那个话题，
历史的问题可能会移入到现在，
会影响现在，
我举个例子别说，
很多人不知道，
在省以上曾经还有更高的地方成绩，
就中央，
大家以为下面就是省，
不对,
我们有段时间50年的之前，
还有大区，
当时中国有五大区，
华中、华北、西南、西北，
东北,
还有西南，
五大区级别很高啊，
那相对富国级架构，
五大区每个区有政治局，
政治局也没有书记，
然后下面才是省委书记，
省委书记又分级，
第一书记和普通书记，
省委书记都不是地方的最高官员，
因为它上面还有区，
就是五大区，
在58年前后，
这五大区取消了，
变成了中央直接管省了，
这其实都不算是很长的历史，
但这个对后面的影响很大，
你看这几个区的，
认为华分的方法还在，
国家考虑政策的时候，
这个也还是有作用的，
这个你看很多人都不知道这个事情，
老师你不说我都不知道，
对呀,
所以我想说什么，
就是说，
如果我们将来要调整区化也不是不可能，
你看,
我们现在全中国是独一无二的五级政府体制，
中央、省、市、县、乡镇，
村都不算了，
因为村不是正式的行政组织，
全世界独一无二的，
全世界没有一个国家有我们的五级体制，
那最终还有个特点，
就是我们的数字技术高度发展，
中央对很多事情的了解比地方还清楚，
我举一个例子变成各种灾情，
一个地方发生火灾了，
最先发现火现在是什么，
不是地方的人，
因为可能在深山里，
是中央气象台和国土部门的摇杆卫星，
他先发现了，
然后到照片紧接着传回去，
他们判断之后发给印济观的部门，
印济观的部门直接就下达指令，
让地方去核实，
核实好了，
马上就判断救护，
你看,
中央很多事情真的比地方还早，
还快,
所以这就出现了一系列变化，
既然我知道你更多的信息了，
我未必需要那么激励你了，
我监督你就可以了，
既然我知道更多信息了，
我就不用那么只看结果了，
我要看过程了，
既然我知道那么的信息了，
那么我就可以直接指挥了，
我就可以越过中间阶层了，
所以你会看到站委管得更多，
更严,
更快,
那如果这样的话，
我们还需要5G政府干什么呢？
如果重要能力赶着它到底，
中间层可以去掉了，
所以一道有趣的题目是，
5G政府中如果要去掉一个，
你会去掉哪一个？
哇，说到我极背发联了，
但是现在很多的确有些重点的那个线，
叫做神管线嘛，
地级是在当中，
其实就起不到一个资源配置，
或者财政配置的一个角色，
因为它这个比如说这个线的产业特别重要，
那神就直接可以管下来，
我觉得这是一种特点，
第二个我前面听到尼尔说的话，
我就是有种，
不叫担忧或者是想法，
就是我们都知道它管理的手段越多，
过程管理的越紧，
某种程度上它会起到一个负激力的效果，
那对于基层的员工来说，
我们看到这不光是公务体系啊，
包括国有企业，
都会广泛存在的一个问题是什么，
10到20年前，
因为我父母都是国有企业，
我老婆也在国有企业，
就是我对国有企业这套东西是非常非常熟悉，
你看国有企业的第一代的管理人，
都是瑞一俊旗，
勇于担当，
敢于创新，
开疆唾吐，
他一定是这样特征的人才才能把一个企业游小做到大，
而且早期的那些管理者，
他和民企的人他没有任何区别，
第一是他一定能信到一流的人才，
因为很有可能有些行业原来是垄断的，
你这个大学这个专业毕业了以后，
你没有民企可去，
你也没办法创业，
你就只能到国企去干这个活，
所以他聚集了最好的人才，
最开放的生态，
然后增速也很快，
但是你越往后面来说的话，
实际上第一是，
竞争格就会发生变化，
你很多人才会流失，
最麻烦的是什么？
到了发展当地阶段，
他最需要的不是你瑞一俊旗，
或者是创新，
他需要的是你求稳，
因为你只有稳稳当当的不出大差子，
对于领导来说，
他才是最安全的，
那慢慢的他就会形成一个负极力的效果，
就是我多做多做，
多去尝试在过程管理和合规检验的过程当，
反而会查出我更多一些问题，
所以这会不会变成一个比较大的一个风险？
对，我觉得杨老师，
你是个很深刻的观察，
这可能不只是国企，
而是所有的组织部门，
所有的单位，
包括民营企业都会面临这样的问题，
当然并不是被办法打破，
我们可以稍后再说，
这辈子原因出到我前面讲的数字技术，
还有一个原因就是什么？
跟经济发展和人口有关，
经济高速正常时期，
那一般都是野蛮生长，
管不过来，
你就弄这个你就弄那个，
反正大家都能赚到钱，
现在经济下行了，
这个也不能承担，
那个也不能承担，
那你要干那么多是干什么呢？
第三个原因就是人口在减少，
你人口在减少，
这是一个非常非常关键的变量，
因为我们的政府架构，
是根据人口来配备公共服务的，
你人口减少了，
公共服务就要减少，
那很多县可能就不需要存在了，
很多乡镇就要合并了，
还有人口减少了，
没有那么多消费来，
也没有那么多的竞争者的空间了，
也就没有那么多事情了，
那上面要管的，
他就更管得过来了，
所以网络是扩张时期更容易倾向分权，
网络是收缩时期更容易倾向集权，
这几乎是个不可避免的局势，
但是他是不是非要这么多干营，
我觉得倒也不一定，
要举个例子，
这个游门社的大象也能跳舞，
就是IBM的那个前CEO把写那么这样的书，
意思就是组织都会变大，
但并不是大就没有活力，
如果你能够分权，
仍然可以保证这个组织有活力，
因为我也可以这么反过来讲，
越是因为今天下行，
越需要放开，
越需要让大家去寻找活力，
越需要激发大家的积极性，
这个时候你就不能管得太严，
你让大家都去找出路不就可以了吗？
当年98年到2001年的时候，
政府部门也搞下岗分流，
那个时候就是让大家去找活路，
有人去经商，
有的人去转岗，
有人去培训，
就应该允许这样用氛围，
这很重要，
但另一方面，
确实在某些领域，
又没有那么多窗险的空间了，
为什么呢？
因为之前有那么多窗险空间，
是因为制度不完善，
现在制度越来越完善了，
那你在制度的规则内，
作为一个政府，
本来就不应该有很多创新，
所有的国家越往后发展，
一定是越趋向于正规化，
但是中国还没有到那个阶段，
我认为中国是一个发展种国家，
我们还是有很多地方要改革，
所以我觉得在当下，
还是需要鼓励创新，
给继承更多的活力，
我在这么说里提到了一个，
概括中国治理成功的一个秘诀，
就四个字，
上下同志，
所以中国的发展就是高层的顶层设计，
和底层的摩托斯都过合集合起来的，
现在仍然需要这样，
现在问题在于，
既然活力越来越小了，
80%的文件，
主要是贯着中央的精神，
也就是说大部分是转发，
地方自主创立的文件，
或者政策措施越来越少，
可能也就20%左右，
这个对于地方的活力是不利的，
因为很多政策，
它需要印地质疑，
中国本来地域差异又大，
比如说我这个地方，
并不是非要搞新的，
汽车不可，
你非要让我搞这个，
那最后可能，
导致才能过身，
自然错配。
那就是包括，
我觉得这也可以再展开讲讲，
像联老师树林提到的这些基层的这些困境和问题，
就比如说关于土地财政，
然后比如说关于目前地方的一些债务问题等等等等，
这个对于大家，
从个体的角度来讲，
要不要进入体制内，
以及如何更好的理解基层的体制，
我觉得都是很有帮助的。
可以啊，
就是我觉得地方债，
是我们面临的最大的挑战之一，
因为地方背负了那么多债务，
你想去好不好说一个家庭，
如果你觉得你还这都还不完，
那你觉得生活就没有希望，
你也不敢去消费，
也不敢去投资，
也不敢去旅游，
所以这个问题必须得想办法解决，
现在的难题在于，
一是我们不清楚，
到底有多少地方的隐性债务，
第二个是，
怎么解决这个问题呢？
就我问过很多地方的官员，
地方官员大多数人会认为，
应该一刀切有中央买断，
比如你说个10点，
在这个事件之前的债务中央全部兜了，
之后的债务地方负担，
这样相当于是赎买制度，
但是这个制度有问题在于，
所有的这个大设也好，
一刀切也好，买断也好，
你必须配套的严格的前提，
就是你能保证以后不再出现，
类似的问题，
还有你会当成横向不公，
因为杨老师借得少，
我借得多，
结果中央一锅端了，
全部给兜走了，
那杨老师和杨老师不公平，
那早知道我也拼命介绍完了，
你这个问题不好解决，
我觉得现在我们并没有相应的配套的制度，
能保证出现这个情况，
如果能保证避免这种情况，
我赞同现在就中央一刀切买断，
否则地方政府被这个负担，
永远无法牵行，
然后,
即便解决这个问题还有问题，
你即便可以解决现在的存量债务问题，
为了怎么办？
地方政府的钱袋子在哪里，
财源在哪里？
如果你不能开源，
也还是不能根本解决这个问题，
但我对这个问题的解决方案是，
分两步走，
一方面地方政府确实要拓展财源，
所有资产都要证券化，
所有的证券都要杠杆化，
我觉得这肯定是一种办法，
但我觉得从产业来看，
最根本的是什么呢？
是政府的职责要转变，
要从一个发展型政府，
变成一个服务型政府，
发展型政府的意思就是，
我是经济发展的火车头，
我不仅自己当裁判员，
我还要下场当运动员，
我觉得这个不对，
中国已经慢慢的变成一个中能发达国家，
那这样的话，
政府不能既当裁判员，
又当运动员，
你这样会扭曲这样的配置，
而且不公平竞争，
那政府仍然可以重视发展，
那就应该让企业去干，
让民营企业去干，
你政府做好裁判员就可以了，
只要政府不自己亲自下场，
政府就没有必要借钱，
政府不必要借钱，
他只要做好公务服务，
他就不会背负那么债务，
还有一个原因就是，
因为官员的任期很短，
省场现金数字这一级差不多三年，
市场市委数字这一级，
2.8年左右，
现在可能更短，
现场现金数字以前是不到三年，
现在可能超过三年，
那么短的任期，
你想如果又没钱可以借，
又不需要你还，
你难道不想借吗？
所以如果你不改变这个基地，
没有用的，
当然你说什么时候把中国。
从一个发展型政府改成一个服务型政府，
这可能需要一个过渡，
并不说一夜之间就改，
但是慢慢的我觉得，
发现是理念要准备的，
就是我们不能让政府。
再去充当经济发展的龙头，
不符合所有国家
进入发展国家的这样一个规律。
那我很好奇，
像尤其是今年，
念老师您到处去调研，
有看到一些比较好的例子，
或者是相对好转的倾向吗？
我确实觉得，
继承的官员已经很卖力了，
很多地方政府，
都已经把发展当作第一要务了，
就是想尽办法，
真的是千方百议，
千言万语，
千山万水，
去找项目，
都是为了这个招商引资。
以前的租金办，
主要的功能是为领导服务迎来送往，
现在的租金办主要是干两件事情，
一个是招商引资，
一个是招财引资，
就是双招双引卖，
功能都变了，
你的地方政府非常着急，
但是我相当有点乐观的情绪是，
中国的经济发展，
不需要太多的刺激，
只要给活力，给空间就够了，
为什么呢？
你看中国老百姓，
特别能吃苦，
特别能耐劳，
特别能想办法，
所以其实只要有足够的空间，
我仍然觉得中国经济，
能够维持中速的增长，
不说高速增长，
起码中速增长是可谓的，
现在问题在于，
很多事情就是管得太多了，
导致大家的空间受到限制了，
这是根本的问题，
假如我们来换个眼光看，
如果地方政府不用去发展经济，
你地方政府刚好迎删环境进行了，
你只要放手让企业去赶，
那企业有的是办法，
你要是问企业，
企业家还是相对比较乐观的，
虽然比较难，
因为经济总有周期嘛，
你变了一个下星期，
肯定是没有钱那么容易挣钱的，
但是还是有很多人能挣到钱，
比如说一些新经济，
中国的新能源就是，
包括新能源汽车，
理电池和太阳能光福，
被称为新商样，
代替了过去的出口的老商样，
以前我们对外出口觉得是靠服装，
电子产品和家具，
现在是新商样，
我们新商业已经赚全世界产能的。
百分之七八十升的更高的比例，
这个可能是最让我感到。
不可思议的经济现象之一，
因为按照正宏的理论，
中国是个发展中国家，
你搞新能源是没有任何优势的，
对吧，你也没有基础，
你可能也没有那么的需求，
不要忘了，
中国以前是一个高乌兰国家，
因为我们是全世界最大的制造业基地，
制造业本来就有乌兰，
所以我们也是消耗全世界最多的煤炭、
矿石、水乌兰也多，
但虽然想到这样一个高乌兰的国家，
居然称为新建能源的，
重要的出口国家和领先国家，
这个很多人都没想到，
我觉得这个也带了一个希望，
其实我觉得中国经济对经济学最大的贡献，
就是让产业政策这四个字去污名化了，
你知道吧，以前在经济学界，
你要上产业政策，
这是个贬义词，
然后自从中国把新鲜产业做起来之后，
产业政策这个词，
就逐渐的变成一个中性词了，
甚至你看连美国也学我们科学新篇法案，
他也搞补贴，搞产业政策，
但我想如果中国能够成功的发展这些行业，
难道就不能成功的发展别的行业吗？
如果有这些产业为榜样，
我们应该能够探索到新路，
再说有出海，
这样一个新城大海般的前景，
中国经济还是有希望的，
就只要我们能够不瞎折腾，
给民间足够的空间，
我觉得一点都没有，
回应我前面说的问题，
机会肯定还是有的，
但你要问我具体哪些行业发展比较好，
我到每个地方我都问这个问题，
问了很多人，
我就想知道有没有什么信心，
他们大部分会告诉我，
大部分行业确实有点走下坡路，
但有几个行业一直在上升，
就是新能源，
输得经济，
这几个方面，
大家公认的就，
这两个已经够大的了，
就是一直处于上升的趋势，
这个大家也能看得到。
嗯,
秦明天老师说到产业竞争的话，
但他是不是第一个是有发展阶段不同，
第二个是有程度的不同，
就比如说我看到你在说里边说到了那个比亚地的那个例子，
我感触其实就比较深的，
我们看到行业刚开始的时候，
他肯定是万马奔腾，
就每个地方都是各自搞，
然后可能其中有70%到80%的地方，
他可能就失败了，
但是有20%他可能就挖掘到了，
像比亚地，
像未来啊，
这样的一些明信公司，
并且持续做大了，
然后地方的经济和地方的财业因此，
获得了巨大的一个好处，
但是再接下来他还会进入到一个新的阶段，
这个企业就会变得期货可居，
接下来各个地方就会说，
那比亚地能不能在我这边开个厂，
你这个特斯拉能不能在我这开个第二工厂，
我给你便宜的地，
我给你招员工，
我给你退税，
然后通过其他的一个方式，
再去更猛烈的一个竞争，
那当他竞争到这个程度上的时候，
总体上来说他的这个过渡竞争，
又使得这个产业很难，
持续性的一个出倾，
你会不会有这样的一个担心在里面？
对，你说的是周期性现象，
那每个产业都有周性现象，
你刚才提到一个问题就是说，
假如产业能过剩了对吧，
一定会有这个阶段，
那我们怎么办？
我想提一个新的思路未必对，
这可以很大胆的思路，
也是我最近一直思考的问题，
我们现在南战，
没有那么多工作岗位来解决就业，
那么假如将来，
可能不远的将来，
我们的盛产率足够发达了，
我们的机器能足够发达了，
我们的AI足够发达了，
可能全世界只需要10%的人去工作，
就可以养好全世界剩余90%的人，
绝大多数人根本就不需要工作，
大家只需要娱乐和过好基本生活就可以了，
那个时候就业可能就是个委问题，
这一天可能不远的将来真的会到来，
所以现在年轻人也不要太焦虑，
其实很多国家已经开始实行。
所谓的全民基本收入保障，
因为世界力足够发达，
根本就不需要那么多工作，
举个例子说，
你看以前80%、90%的人是农民，
现在我们需要吗？
那世界人干什么？干别的，
以后都不需要那么多人生产，
所以我们现在真的要考虑。
我们的政府治理结构，
如果90%的人不一定需要工作，
大家干什么？可以搞文艺创众，
可以写小说，
可以去画画，
也可以去郊游，
那政府应该把这些养起来，
因为这个钱已经足够了，
而且我们这个时代。
不需要那么多马斯克，
可能一个马斯克就够了，
以后也不需要牛马，
以后也不需要中国经济学家，
对呀,
所以所有的人可能都要想这个问题，
这个问题可能听上去有点遥远，
但是它是渐进式的，
政府要做好这个准备，
将来就不可能有这么多工作岗位，
就后面说，
你看你刚才讲到比亚迪，
如果你去探光它的无能工厂，
你发现它不需要什么人了，
我们上次去湖南调研的时候，
我就发现很奇怪，
乡镇工厂都是只有三四个人，
都是机械化了，
就是会减少就业了，
所以制造业将来一定是逐渐减少就业，
对，前段时间不是深圳还有一个新闻吗？
说是南山区还是哪个区的，
一个政务部门，
然后用AI帮他们处理了很多东西，
然后导致网上很多人就焦虑说，
会不会公务员未来也要被AI取代了？
这是完全有可能的呀，
而且我们的研究发现，
政府部门在这些年，
政府采购中用于AI相关的支出比例越来越高，
反正已经接近14%，
所以不只是公务员，
所有的部门，
整个全世界都面临这种问题，
将来注定不需要那么多的工作，
好，那我问一个问题，
政府做好了准备让这些人干什么吗？
我们还成文科多了，
将来没有文科这些人干什么去，
我跟他说以后只有文科能提供大家娱乐和情绪价值，
所以我觉得，
对年轻人现在其实就是说，
你除了好好学习，
无力工作之外还要学会怎么会玩，
你将来也是不会玩啊，
你想想看你将来多无聊，
别说很多学者，
他除了学论文，
他就不会干别的，
这种人将来老了就极度无聊的，
对，但是年轻人会说，
你老是你说了很多，
我先把目前的这三年过去再说，
对，或者我先把债还完再说，
我觉得你老是说到的这个东西，
我们大家都能理解，
包括在美国加州很多的学者，
也在探讨这样的一种可能性，
现实状况是，
我觉得现在无论是政府，
无论是企业还是个人，
他首先还是面对的就是一个债务问题，
一方面觉得说，
哎呦，我这条路好像越走越窄，
另外一方面我又停不下脚步，
因为一旦停下脚步了以后，
我没有办法去偿还这样的一个债务，
对，我觉得这个压力的确是很大的，
对，我觉得要看部门，
就我们把所有的债务分成三个部门，
政府部门，企业部门和居民部门，
居民部门的债务不用太担心，
你基本上，
省之减用可能能把债还清的，
而且现在利息也得降，
家庭的资产负债表会变得更好，
这是毫无疑问的，只需要时间，
那企业也不用太担心，
只要它是市场化的企业，
麻烦的是政府，
因为政府的债务，
要么由中央兜下来，
要么通货膨胀相当于变相合销，
要么传递给下一代，
我认为基本上只有在三种主要方法，
大家能接受哪种呢？
可能最后三管齐下才够，
这个真的不容易，
我觉得这是当下最严重的治理挑战之一，
去到之一都不为果。
那站在个体的角度来讲，
尤其是听到我们前面分析，
尤其是分析了地方政府面对的债务问题，
以及未来怎么化解，
那我觉得大家可能心越听越凉，
这个公务到底考还是不考，
该考还是要考，
但是呢，
所以我说要选城市很重要，
你不能去一个收收性城市，
如果一个人口在流失，
经济在下行，
你去那个地方，
但它好上岸，
所以你要全行这个风险，
你不能说我找个地方又好上岸，
将来还能躺定，
这是不可能的，
没有在那选，
如果又有这样的选项，
所有人都会发现，
我最建议一般的人不要去这种地方，
因为将来你可能真的可能会下岗分流，
公务员是不会直接裁员，
但他会分流你，
然后把你调到边缘部门里去不去，
所以不存在真正的铁饭馆，
金饭馆都会被打破，
更不用说铁饭馆，
所以我这样，
要避开那些收收型城市，
这是第一，第二呢，
作为家庭要少举债，
这个非常重要，
如果你的部门举债了，
你又举债了，
那这就很难对冲风险了，
血上加双，
对对,
然后呢就说，
要好好锻炼身体，
如果你熬到后面身体好，
说不定将来真的不用工作了，
这是完全有可能，
我都甚至乐观的认为，
在我还在世之间，
可能都能看到这样的现象，
就是将来真的大部分人是不用工作的，
或者说工作的形势已经不再是为了谋生，
而就是为了娱乐，
让这个社会更和谐，更稳定，
这可能就是国家这里的目标之一，
对，一下子感觉就是思路都打开了，
这只是咱们一个畅想，
但是我相信这一定是未来的方向，
只是时间问题，
对，可能现在这个对我们来说，
还是是一个需要探讨，
甚至有很多政变的问题，
也许过了三年五年，
当真的这个潮水来临的时候，
这些东西都是不变自明的，
是的,
嗯,
聂老师你说的一句话非常好，
就是人真的应该多了解一下政治经济学，
了解很多我们看起来理所当然的事情，
背后的一些运行逻辑，
这样才能做出更符合个人，
符合家庭，
符合不管短期还是长期利益的一些决策，
是的,
嗯,
你接下来下一本新书什么时候出啊？
写的是什么？
等级,
等级?
对，我可以预告一下，
肯定要写这个方向，
也是写行政体制的这个？
不是,
可能会更广泛，
因为我觉得自古以来，
等级在资源配置中起着非常重要的作用，
但是我还没有想清楚，
因为这方面的基础还不够，
我还需要学习，
好的,
那期待聂老师的新书，
也期待未来聂老师能带新书，
来小酒馆跟我们好好聊一聊，
没问题，
好，谢谢聂老师，
谢谢聂老师，
以上就是本期的全部内容，
如果你觉得这期节目有收获有启发，
欢迎你把它转发给你关心的亲友，
如果你能听到这里，
我想你大概也能感受到，
这一期我们并没有试图给出一个简单的结论，
不是因为这个问题有些敏感，
而是因为，
像要不要考功，
要不要去基层这样的选择，
本来就不应该被压缩成一句推荐，
一个结论。
聊到最后，
我其实还想补充一个背景，
这是聂老师在这本书的前言里写到的，
给我留下了很深的印象。
他说，自己出生在江西省福州市重人县的一个贫困农村，
一路读书，进城，
有幸从一个放牛瓦成长为名牌大学的教授，
作为一个提着笔杆子进城的人，
在他的内心深处，
总有一种难以割舍的相土情怀。
所以对聂老师来说，
基层从来都不是一个抽象的研究对象，
而是他非常熟悉，
也始终牵挂的故土与相亲。
我也会再想，
聂老师之所以会长期去做地方政府和企业相关的研究，
通过这本书，把基层的这些运转逻辑摊开来讲，
很大程度上，
也是希望更多人在做选择之前，
能多了解一些真实情况。
至少在我看来，
正和他自己的成长经历是分不开的。
听完整期节目，再回头看他的前言，
其实会发现，
他做的很多事情都围绕着同一个核心。
不是告诉你该怎么选，
而是尽量把你看不到，
也很难提前知道的那部分现实，
提前摆在你面前。
如果这期节目，
能让你在做判断之前，
多问自己几个更具体的问题，
而不是只想要一句简单的结论，
那我会觉得，
这期节目已经完成了他该完成的事情。
最后也和大家说一个小福利，
如果你愿意在评论区认真写下你的想法，
我们会从中选出五条留言，
送出聂辉华老师亲笔签名的新书，
基层中国的运行逻辑。
也很欢迎你在评论区分享你的感受，
或者你自己的亲身观察。
节目里聊到的，
是聂老师基于长期研究和一线观察展开的讨论，
而你的经历，
可能正好能补充那些书本和研究之外的具体细节。
之前也有不少朋友问，
相关的获奖信息会在哪里公布？
我们会直接在评论区回复，
或者通过私信联系你确认地址，
也请大家注意分辨相关信息。
再次感谢你愿意把时间留给这样一期不太轻松，
但是我们都非常认真对待的对话。
感谢你的收听，
这里是知情小酒馆。
如果你喜欢我们的节目，
欢迎订阅收藏，
也非常欢迎你把他分享给你关心的人。
我是宇白，
每周晚8点，
我们不见，
不散。